[音楽]
no こんにちは
お笑い作家の倉本美津留
と申します
はいっ
長きにわたってですねー
とはいえの仕事をずっと続けてきていまし
てえ
まあ
いい笑いをですねまあテレビとかラジオと
か放送で発信したいなぁと思って色々やっ
てるんですけども笑ってめちゃめちゃ大事
だと思ってるんですねうーんあの笑いの
感情あるのは人間以外の動物で寝ないし
a
まあ人間に与えられた特権だと思うんです
よね
でなんかこう落ち込んだ時でも笑うと急に
なんかこう楽しかったりとか
ネガティブをポジティブに変える瞬間的に
変えるなんかスイッチのようなもんだと
思うんですよ
まああの元にも効くとかってねいう報告も
あったりしてあのそのスイッチをですね
できるだけたくさん増やしたいなぁと思い
ながら僕仕事してもう40年頃立つんです
けども
まああのやっぱり日常に笑いがどんどん
増えていくということが
ん
が世の中良くなっていくと思ってまして
で
笑える
ヒントがもうそこらじゅうに転がってるん
ですよね
あの僕も漫才あのの仕事してますけども
漫才でボケとツッコミたでしょ
で冒険は僕らももうほっといてもう
ちょっとよくわからないけども
すっぽんたらそこで笑いパーを切るじゃ
ないか
あれたのは凄いスイッチたと思うんですよ
ね
でよねぼけてることがいっぱいあってそれ
みんなね丁数してきてるんですよ
ちょっとあの三方開でね角度を変えてみ
たら気づいてボケにそれ突っ込んだら笑い
がポンと生まれてくるということだけです
例えばあの今皆さん一番関心あるのは何か
というとやっぱりオリンピックですよね
オリンピック a いろんな意味ですごい
話題じゃないですかこの時期この
タイミング
このオリンピックはの今年
東京であるのでいろいろ競技増えました
けども
何競技がありますか
これオリンピック33協議で
パラリンピックで言うと55競技あるん
ですけども
33協議はこれですね
はいっ
でっ
これ見てなんかこう
ああっと思うことですか
ちょっとボケてるやんみたいな
ゴチコみたいですよねー
これですよ
いやほとんどおり上で行ってる中
ねぇ
いやいや陸上競技だけ別みたいな感じなん
でしょこれ言いますこれこれ陸上で行った
a の木の下のちょっとだけですよ
あと全部陸上でありますかね
後編
水泳もネリコ2穴掘ってね日辞令でバザー
でてるでしょ
あれ無理二種ですからそんなもう
バスケットボールもサッカー星も全部ね案
をこの隙間から上全部陸上ですからじゃあ
なりくしょーっていう教義学わけですよ
なんじゃそらってを巻く座標を考えたら
ロランマイナーも思わんと我々多いでしょ
こ突っ込んでは内戦と全部リーグの上で
あとね腕ね
いうた方がいいわけですよ
対処
体操もねまあ六朝ですよね体操は体操見た
こと言われますけど
体操で
こういう庶務課でしょ
鉄棒って言っ
スタックりしてもない頃
鉄の棒なんてねあれ以外んナンボ de
barcelona かねえしかもあの
公園の鉄棒でまでてスっぽいけど
対象の鉄棒田中哲ぽくない何か
直結号言ってねえっ
だが皆こう
すごい
あの競技なって付
全世界鉄棒で揺れますがねいやいやもう
ちょっとなんか名前あのちゃんかと思う
でしょ
突っ込んだらわかるじゃないですか
ツッコミなど何もわからないでしょ
が
でその
オリンピックには各国から小洒落た世界
から社会から空くる国の名前の表記も
寝ぼけてるんですよねえ
これ
アメリカのことでしょ米国
いや米の国はない中
どちらところ日本のことでしょ
米木切って
アメリカ中に行くとか小麦粉が主たる
ところだね
肉航空とかきた方ホッピー人もですよね
えっこれをずっとそうも使ってる
なんじゃそれとねこれ
フランスっいや仏の国でこれ
いやいやこれはもうお釈迦さんが生まれた
空気からインドのことでしょうっていう
ことになんかこうこれをフランスだと思え
てなってるでしょ
ボケてるじゃないですかこんなんだかと
いうと骨戦前にね感じで全もう一回の熱海
た時ねあーメイリーカーは4ランスとで
読めるようにでも漢字を当てはめたわけ
ですよ
アメリカの泡アジアのあーに咲き捉えてる
わけでしょ
アジアに取られてるからも次の米屋メー
ディアティアやらなきゃいけない麺は細6
になるから日本なんか読むところ誰か4
変型
アフロスのもうこれもっと違う風やって
やろうとなんてパサート仏やランドで物を
選んでです噴火っていうのは[ __ ]
なんかこそどうなっとんねんと思うんです
よ
もう24年もそんなことだらけ
もう朝起きてからありますよ
朝起きて朝食でモーニングと思うんだね今
出てきますからね
a
朝からメジャー枚焼いて食べても
ボーンカー横須町
卵をじゃないですか
目玉役って言うでね
これみんなねそれをし過ぎめ来たクマ
なんか入ってないってねイワナダメなん
ですよ子何にも思わないでしょうでも
持ち込んだそういうことですからね
日常的に良いくねこれね
散髪月に一度くらい行くでしょ
いやいや神チラシに入ってどうすんねんっ
て話ですよ
整えいいってわけですからそれ髪切ったら
切ったが道りますよ
ねそっちをメインにいうてどうすんでい
たら頭じゃないですかね
大革新口とそのままじゃあねこれこれこれ
これします
この子加工人差し指でしょ
人差し指ねん
声でね一刺したねを母に怒られるんですよ
他社破顔言っていっ
良い人差し指で描いてあるやんけど
さやかやってるのに入っての来られるの間
やりたマリアン系ってね女他の名前性と
いうわけですよ
レアリたナビアンケ心構えさえっていうの
でねこんなありますはこれ
各星座
これねっ
名前良すぎるんですよ
ね覚醒する2レースは各社で目覚めるとか
次の政治に行けるみたいなねこんな a
名前やってたらそりゃでなくならへんはと
やりたそうに猫ええがなええなぁ意味で
ダメダメ今度はもっと悪い名前だなぁなん
ですこれは悪い名前にして僕日死生観とで
だから覚せい剤って言いたいんやったら
もう漢字の当て字を変えますこうやってね
を
世の中から隔離されるひとりぼっちなので
と
こっちでかつ経済という実施したらもう
そんなんやこのペーだしたそうなるわー
やばいやばい楽しいですか上の学生だった
木はめっちゃエヤーなるよだからなくなる
んですよ名前変えた方がいいですよね
でね逆にね悪い名前成井ねみんな総務&
そのまんま流通してる者ありますこれです
ね
未亡人
ね旦那さんに先立たれた奥さんがこういう
風に呼ばれてあのから3本者られてねえと
私未亡人でとか言うけどもいやにこれを見
てまだなくなってない人ですよ
林ね中のかって話ですこれだんだしみんな
何度もしねーよみたいな言葉です今度は
ダメでしょ
これは皆スルーしすぎなんですよね3号地
はで公開ましょ
ねっ
美しき希望を持って生きていく人ね旦那
さんのことを胸に秘めて私あなた部分が
できるよああ
強く平定組でやれことが大事だと思うん
ですよね
あの婆その
いい言葉を
じゃあ良くない言葉いいことは風にすると
かね悪い言葉をそのままスルーするとかね
なんかね日本語でねそのボケてるっていう
かね間違ってると告げているのがいっぱい
あるんですよね例えばこれですよねこれ
適当ねちゃ名前が件が入ってねなんか
すごい悪いことみたい売れてるでしょ
そのままでも敵とめちゃめちゃちょうど
いいしね
加減がいいわけですよこんな l 言葉を
ねあたみたいに使うじゃないですか
これはねやっぱりダメですこの牛だ
ねっ
でね僕が一番ねそんなネガティブな音言葉
に先頭でくれよと思うのがこれなんですね
これで履かないと思うわけですよ
えっにんべんじゃない人が今持ったら履か
ないかと
夢もターンの間みたいなこの子なんですよ
これダメで喋っ人間言えなかったらね
ね何が楽しいで木10連てくださってです
から
夢なんか持つなよみたいなことを言ってる
感じ嫌じゃないですか
だけだねゆーめーてー何なのかという事
ですよ
夢ってね皆さん2つあると思ってるでしょ
寝る寝ているときに見る夢
でもう一つは将来こうなりたいっていう
思いが来夢ね
二つあると思っているんですかなのにね
いいかたこれしかないんですよ
滋賀と思いません
両方ともで夢としか言えないんですよ
お菓子など僕を持ってこれは怪しいろうと
思って
これ同じ子どもしかねぇタンといっしょ
なんちゃうかと
思ったですよ
そう思うと
寝てる時の夢ってなんかあ
彼女と付き合いたいとか金持ちになりたい
とかって思ったことをすぐに何かを喧嘩
ね思いであるやんか
あ
夢が粉っての夢の中ですぐにねっ
でもを聞いてて将来野球選手になりたいな
とかねあー
彼女と付き合いたいなーとか思うでもね
そんなすぐに出来ませんよね夢叶いません
よねそうなんでかというと
寝てる時でば時間を超越している感覚なん
ですね4次元の感じですよ
だから幼児部屋からもう時間ちょいする
からをもとかパッと叶うんですよね
でも大きいている時は我々は3次元の存在
ですから時間を超越で時間を自由にでき
ない
だからめちゃめちゃ時間がたっても
しゃあないですこれでもかなうということ
を夢という言葉で一つで表記すると思うよ
だから起きている時は時間かかるけども
叶うんですよ諦めんだったらね
akira メールとかなは来なくなると
ねだから叶うっての夢という言葉で教えて
もらってるのにワームリヤ止めようとなん
ですね
さあ勿体ない話なんですよだから同じだと
思ってて仕方がない時間かのはね時間が
かかるかでも夢を描いた夢っていうのは寝
てる時に夢が叶うように絶対にか叶う
3次元の存在だから時間はかかる
って思って夢がせた諦めたらダメなんです
ねうーん
これ
見たと思います
ああっ
どんな感じ思えばました
ね
これですよね
創造というな中思い描くということですか
思いつく
ね横創造
でも同じ創造という言葉でこれありますよ
ね
これ
これツクールクリエイティブね作り上げる
これはねえっ
想像というね日本語の音で同じ音で
をも描くとつくるっていうことがも同じ
言葉が出る理由その耳で聞いた
っていうことがこれは僕ね夢と同じが一緒
なと思うんですよ
思い描いたことを諦めずにね忘れずに
絶対 a はとこ作りたいと思って作って
頑張って頑張ってやったら想像できるん
ですよ想像した途端にも肖像になってるの
にみんな諦めている
しつこくやったらね絶対で生み出せるん
ですねうん
イマジネーションがクリエイティブにもう
直轄してるこういうことですねこれも=だ
と思いましょうねやっぱり
その形にしたいもんでねやっぱり役に立つ
者だってとかねひらめきじゃないですか
例えばこうやって皆さんにお子喋ってるね
行ったくさんの人に大きな声をを届ける
ためには阿部んだ
2の何もない行為だ届かへんからもっと何
かこうでかいホテルもないかなぁと思って
マイクをね考えたけど怒るわけですよねっ
何がもっとでかい声で聞こえも与えない
なぁと思うけどまぁ無理かーだけ止めたら
これないんですよ
しかもこんなんで最近じゃですか
ブーブ予定ソロそうなんですよそうそうの
創造者なくる
持ったらそれだけのことなんですね
その創造するためにやっぱりひらめきが
必要なわけですよいいきらめきがいい
ひらめきを形にしたいねひらめきよね
やっぱりね僕なんかもそのいっぱい枚目た
なあかん仕事しますからうんキラメキたい
わけですよ
ヘアメキってな過去ずっとなんか枚剥い
たりとかだが降りてくるような感じなん
ですよねうんそのおいてこのような感じで
パッドであってあそれは競った形にしたい
ですごくやってて生まれたら誰もまだ見た
こともない素敵な者が生まれたりするん
ですようんでもねその閃きというのがその
簡単にネス草履で来ないんですよねえもう
な底何も考えても枚ばかりのときはよく
あるんですよ苦しいときか
これなんかもコンスタントに枚目けるなん
かこうパターンというか
なんかないかなと思ってね悩んでたわけ
ですよ
悩みながらひらめきてずーっと見てたん
なあーと思ったでしょ
これもん
門構えに人でしょ
門のところに人がやってきてるんでしょ
なるほどーと僕のイメージではインスベー
ションっていうのを降りてきてねっ
で自分がキャッチしたらひらめいていると
いうことになると思うんですねでも人間は
いつもねその脳に扉が閉まっている状態と
思うぞ
それが開いてる時にな合理的な入れると
思う
それが自然に開いたけばんだけどもっ
大概は閉じている
でも投資出るのを
ね自分の門の鍵柄に合う鍵を持って人が
やって来てくれて
がちゃんと開けてくれたら版と開いてパン
と降りてっ
だからよくねー
同じ人ギアのに女日本人者がいい女2本を
使ってのに喋ってても全然スターてない
なぁあの人っていうのとあんまりじゃない
のに何でこんな伝わるのっていう人いる
でしょ
ね誰でもいると思うんですよ
ん
だからそれは鍵穴の形とか木と会ってる人
がでしょ
[拍手]
here 第二してくださいそれをやり方
にするとどんどん枚剥いていくんですね
こういうことですよだからねこうやってき
てがちゃんと開けてくるうん謎落ち降りて
くる不在平井前田ことをもったえない
なくないように形にするということですね
はい
猫の足だってねこれ前にし毎日こう見る
ような子じゃないですか
当たり前ねこれ見ててね防衛大発見したん
ですよ
これはほんまにあしたようなと思うんです
よ
まあ明るい日と書いてで明日ですけども
これほんまに押したようなところね分解し
たのねこうですよ
一がーでで月が出て火が出て太陽出て次は
出てたけど1日経ってるでしょ
ブーブーあったらどうやてぃあ効果あ料金
っていうのはどっちが
ティ8ソナー建明日明日明日どんどん
どんどんどんどん明るく
パドドゥだーっ
here どんどん
アティこれを傷だとやっぱなんやもうその
不安になってばじゃんかーんーもう未来
羽毛明日も今日と明日のかね寝てたら明日
何年かなってどんどんどんどん開かなく
なるはもう明るくなると思って自分の
気持ちも明るくしていくっていうね
ことでどんどん考えていく
そんなことばかり考えて中でを笑える人が
笑顔になることを考えてるんですけども
この笑笑時代一体何なのかですね
ちょっとそっからは第二代などの形で笑
っていうのはないやと思った時に笑いを音
アルファベット転換したよ笑
こう見たときびっくりたのがぽれ
ブーブ予定ということは笑いや戦争愛に
変え4つ入っだそういう言葉なんですよ
日本のは相手だからに仕様にはないよねー
いっぱい増やしてみんなね不正のように
母権いっぱい突っ込んでお笑い作ってで
世界を平和にしましょう
ありがたう
[音楽]